so jetzt wieder von hinten den kumpels
helfen hier schön gar kein kill
abgestoppt aber egal wie spät fürs team
irt spiel fürs team sagte ballett schott
gibt da denen jetzt gehen wir hier über
den außen weg gehen putzen wahlkampf
derzeit frieden will ich nicht sagt er
macht er noch ein kind
hier kämpfen geht nicht schnell der
kongress seine augen überall leute und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen runde
halo pop gestorben
kein plan wieso abo klicken gestorben
ich habe keinen 13 zu 5 kg fund aus 13 3
wegen aufnahme blablabla ein bisschen
runtergegangen
für mich ist das schon gut ich weiß
einige von euch ein richtig toller
hengst und meinen dann immer in den
kommentaren oder kann ich gar nicht
angreifen darauf eine granate ich dass
mein team und meine 410 0
du bist voll packen hub ich weiß ich
habe nie gesagt dass ich gut bin nur
gesagt das ist endlich mal ein pvp spiel
in dem ich das wissen was reißen kann
also in dem ich auch mal so eine bessere
kg als 1 habe ich weiß kennen jetzt
nicht die ganze maps auswendig aber ich
hoffe auf jeden fall wieder bock auf
halo ich werde euch diesmal nicht die
server ab in die kommentare schreiben
das war letztmals die ganze zeit war das
volk 1
die ganze zeit waren die server voll da
konnte ich gar nicht spielen das war
richtig ärgerlich er nicht nach plan
soll die swisscom jetzt in japan
da muss ich ja wohl meinen links stapler
auspacken 30
ich konnte ich die ganze zeit nicht
spielen ganz einfach aus dem grund weil
der server die ganze zeit voll war wie
lonza darf sich natürlich gut wenn euch
das gefällt wäre doch selber spielen
wollt allerdings kann ich dann natürlich
weniger aufnehmen ob man ist nicht
gestorben
er kann ich dann natürlich weniger
aufnehmen wenn ihr dann die ganze darauf
fällt deswegen als vikar googeln ich
werde mich definitiv die stierkampfarena
oder 16 kommentare schreiben weiß es
nicht also was wäre ich lieber dass ihr
die server ip bist du die ganze zeit
rauf spielen können oder dass ich halt
je mehr aufnehmen das könnt ihr mal
schreiben
und ja es kommt ausschuss zahlen
wenn ich jetzt schon in der base von
denen nehme das keinem welt okay gut
übrigens was mir auch sehr viele
geschrieben haben wie man klassen
wechselt das ist mein callya man wie man
klassen wechselt habe ich allerdings
wieder vergessen
ich glaube dass gegen die am anfang mit
/ kit oder so aber ich hab's halt
vergessen deswegen ist nicht so toll
ach so das sind ja cool werde ich bei
mir zu hause raus teleportiert klasse
was macht er denn eine rüstung okay und
was das hier ein bisschen absperrung
ok cool was ich mag auf jeden fall die
maps weil es ja hallo maps enthalten
und ich habe auch passt das texture pack
dazu also passt alles hier in dem spiel
lag allerdings nur freunde mit
lamborghini massaker 18 24 akademie für
mich ist das gut freunde braucht jetzt
nicht wieder hier ich bin viel besser
was sind hier drin sind die schulen drin
schon ein keine schuhe
na gut da muss ich wohl wieder mit
lamborghini tiefer als am boden trifft
um die kurve na gut so das sind so paar
zitate die sind hat mit chet baker botts
gerade wenn mehrere leute spielen ja
jetzt kommen wir wieder mit dem sperma
kann löhnen an alter 1000 schuss auf
einmal nicht wenn das ein milliönchen
milch und klein links bundes von ganz
kleinen kong graf das kommunale raus
also wollt ihr lieber mehr halo also
habe ich ja schon gesagt ich wollte erst
hier sowieso will gamestop man auf der
kann ich ja nicht angreifen für drauf
ich wollte erste business sowie games
auf nehmen auf pixel oder halt einfach
daniel craig kraft oder duos oder irgend
sowas aber das kommt ja alles noch neu
jetzt gerade hatte ich in die box
aber ich hatte den server noch eine
liste dach besuchen der war bisher immer
voll
kannst ja mal hier auf gut glück so
einfach mal probieren da dachte ich mir
jolo probiert einfach mal bleibt stehen
bleibt stehen
ja habe ich ihn gut abgefangen
jetzt stellt mich hier drauf
a immer klappt so drei reload ein
bisschen hier bewegen
der war doch der war auch der war ja
bloß laufach man so nach laden wieder 14
4 das ist für mich schon eine gute kg
freunde checker den ubc liqing wird wohl
in ihrer hand das kann man ganz kurz
freundin jetzt wissen wir hier auch die
man wechselt braucht jetzt nicht
schreiben na ja das ist ja das ist freut
mich ja gut dann müssen wir das jetzt
auch mir gefällt zwar die sniper rifle
so ein bisschen also damit 30 schon
immer gute scores soviel zum vierten
ergeht schon ab und ich mich ein 14 4
system welche anderen schlechteren als
ich deswegen nicht der rechte und jetzt
kommt der mit der battery und macht gar
keine kinski war das überhaupt kein
schaden machen da geh ich halt nahkampf
vor allem blockierten weg
jung stehen bleiben soll ach so mit 4300
alter der war gut ich hatte glaube ich
2000 oder sogar noch weniger
ich weiß doch gar nicht was den ganzen
kisten der immer am anfang drin ist in
der nähe ich nehme mein schönes mädchen
bekomme ich ja gar nicht glauben wenn
schöne schnäppchen piloten freunde reden
so der steeb dt john mac hat doch nicht
geschafft
ach man wann ich denke so sniper shotgun
soll dritten mal ins all drittel ist es
anders davon habe ich noch mehr schuss
mir wird niemals eine waffe gefallen wo
man einfach wirklich nur gedrückt halten
kann so eine mg quasi wo man übels
fehlschuss hat gibt es bestimmt schon
jetzt sind schon die ersten fleißigen
schwitzenden kommentarschreiber wieder
am rauf tippen auf der tastatur weisen
nicht nur das ist dass hier mehr oder
weniger alter die müssen sich doch
irgendwie verarscht fühlen die komm
runter und sachsen sie tot und ich mach
einfach kein geld
ich habe schon drei kills neu ich freue
mich dass immer wichtig denn meine kills
her
hmm naja dadurch dass jetzt übrigens die
klausurphase endgültig vorbei ist mathe
noch geschrieben übels verkackt bei 36
grad nein ich liebe es verkackt aber sap
machte ich hatte erste platte schon 3+
deswegen war es egal
steht kein defizit hat zwar im abi am
main ich lernen dafür nicht hatte nicht
so viel gelernt deswegen gegen drei
priester voll klar und ja bla bla ich
leute ihr wisst was ich meine seite
geschrieben gibt noch immer viel
passieren
genau markiert hier direkt im shop
eigentlich ganz einfach mal eine
handgranate reinschmeißen apropos die
must be santa cruz teenager sein muss
muss auch ja 80 euro damit die spartan
nutzen kann ja auch kein ding freunde
macht ja nix
ich habe die leute hier schon
angeschrieben ob ich eventuell youtuber
werden könnte haben sich zurück
geantwortet obwohl das ganz normale
leute sind also nicht mehr mit youtube
account oder viel stress oder so und so
ein hype pixel antworte mir danach nach
ein paar stunden auf ein halbwegs server
mich direkt youtube als stadtmensch
masse portner der pixel viele schon ist
ein echt korrekter typ freunde pixel
wert hat nicht kennt oder den nicht
kennt einfach mal alle abonnieren
freunde dadurch direkt wieder drei kills
gemacht im disney co ihr könnt mir ja
einfach in kommt ein fast ihr sehen
wollt wollt ihr mehr halo wollt ihr mehr
hunger games wollt ihr mehr
die aktion macht dabei habe ich bock
drauf oder wollt ihr mal cops and
robbers oder wollt ihr mal ist da meine
ankam hatte ihr wisst was ich meine
deswegen schreibt einfach in die
kommentare
und dann werde ich mich stark machen
wolle phase vorbei ich habe zeit und die
auch dann geht's ab ich habe immer noch
nur 970 punkte das ist relativ wenig die
ganze zeit
lucia ich glaube er wollte schreien
dienstag
ich stelle mir auch allem weg ist
natürlich doppelt wird ich sollte mich
erst mal kurz hier erstmal nach land hat
eine shotgun ist ja gut shotgun könnte
theoretisch auch mal austesten shotgun
sind so zwei drei schüsse auf einmal
beziehungsweise ein großer schuss aber
große schneebilder gibt sich deswegen
glaube ich zu drei auf einmal relativ
zerstreut allerdings mit der dreifachen
wirkungen an wiens na wenn man denn
trifft und nur auf kurze distanz oder
alles mw wissen in die 2 das traurig
ja schon killer das war doppelt il
killer geschafft dann läuft bei mir das
eine gute taktik hätte so stirbt der
nähe
man könnte es kempen nennt man könnte es
auch spot nennen ja ich bin ein bisschen
verrückt drauf weil 36 grad heute ich
lag ich war am pool und legen sie auf
matratze und pen im pool ein
und dann lag ich da zwei stunden sind
übels brown als ich bin allgemein ja
schon relativ bronner typ das hat man ja
auch in den letzten face cam videos
gesehen ja vielleicht bald wiederkommt
die fans gewerbe gesagt vielleicht kommt
immer wieder an und ja freunde mussten
muss man gucken was sie daraus ergibt
das war die erste die hier gespielt
die zweite dame mal da oben aber jetzt
nicht gang und putz es liegt auch ich
bin tot l'aquila
super wenn slate super super sniper wenn
das jetzt nicht läuft hier mit schott
dann erst mal nachladen jungs
ohne witz warum höre ich nicht mehr
diese töne weil ich hab grad zwei leute
getötet habe ich ja trotzdem dieses ihr
wisst was meine häufig das hlr and green
integrationsplan stelle mich drauf hat
auch der ist bei mir
donkey kong remake machen sie den baum
er schlägt sie mit denn so guckt habe
ich jetzt schon wieder in kiel aber ich
habe kein wieder kein ton gehört
irgendwie voll crazy daheim weg hier so
ein bisschen ergriffen wird verdammt eng
ach so was machen wollte ich schnappe
ich mir jetzt mit diashows
wir kämpfen geht nicht schnell der
kongress der in seinen augen überall
überall adedy hier hoch schön hoch
schwimmen natürlich das schiff gedrückt
lassen am kann den namen singen als
kamer trotzdem sehen mittlerweile alles
ist einfach anders
die können von oben dann einspringen
wenn der getroffen hätte alter
er habe ich jetzt will bekommt mehr hab
ich nicht für dich auch nicht was soldat
freunde ich werde mit und eindeutig
benachteiligt werde ich hier saßen
killer killt mich weniger leben habe
oder weil ich's kill habe warmen ins in
ihr in dem dings gibt's kein skill hier
gibt es einfach nur sehr oft spielen und
nicht sehr oft spielen
das gel oder sowas gibt's nicht ich
warte jetzt einfach dass ich reinkomme
und jetzt
hier oben noch ein handy hoch dann
nehmen wir natürlich den hier unten und
den tut mir auch noch eben schnell dahin
kein plan ist falsch sie ist
verschwunden
nein verdammt egal ich hab nur 19 3 d 3
blatter lange jetzt endlich eine minute
danach machen kann
alter wieso kann man wiederum nicht
abschießen
sag doch mal hier mensch
bitte nicht das ist deren spawn da oben
alter legal ist dass dan brown mein gott
ich habe gar nicht drauf geachtet ob
gegenwehr von der seite kommt wieder so
aber jetzt vorbei aber die map ist die
map ist geil sondern gespielt aber ich
weiß welche das ist ja ich glaub ich
kenne bisschen aus halo ich hab ich
leider kein killer ist das team von
ihnen kommen freunde wird eine xxl runde
hey jungs
ich gebe mir runter nach laden runde
soll es erstmal ein bisschen ausruhen
ok leben läuft wieder bei mir immer im
nahkampf navy im nahkampf seit im märz
ort in der hand nehmen ja auch wieder
klasse hat er das gemacht jetzt hier
einfach von hinten aus hinterhalten
natürlich den kumpels freuen den kumpels
freuen den kumpels natürlich dann helfen
in solchen situationen muss grad ein
bisschen leise reden von motorrad her
es ist halb zwölf ist es mit einer woche
ich nehme auf was man nicht alles machen
so jetzt wieder von hinten den kumpels
helfen hier schön gar kein killer
abgestoppt aber es egal die spieler fürs
team irt spielen für das team sagt
tablett schott gibt bei denen jetzt
gehen wir hier über den außen weg gehen
putzen kampf der zeit frieden will ich
nicht sagt er macht er noch ein kind
jetzt gehen wir hier einfach hin man das
war natürlich die große chance hier auf
den klassenerhalt des msv duisburg
konnten sie jetzt nicht ausnutzen ist ja
auch relativ latif relativ jolo
das war triple das war als verdoppelt
stirb kollege stirn steht kollege wie
dumm
nein nein keine munition an egal ich
habe mit zehn zu vier akw für mich geht
das klar
ich glaube ich habe insgesamt bisher
eine 3 d ich habe eine relativ gute
präzision bzw ich mache dieses komische
blüten
dass ich dann mit drei auf freeload gehe
und dann wieder mit 1 dann auf anderen
also dieses wort team als das glaube ich
meine ich kann das damals noch durch mp3
deswegen ich wusste nicht dass das bei
minecraft gibt also das hat mir hier
onic bei den richtigen hunger games
gezeigt wo man dann mit suppen und
agieren muss man vorher wieso diese
welche getroffen
mein gott freunde wenn man sowas spielt
muss man natürlich auch immer das auge
haben
das auge für den freien gegner und es
dann trotzdem nicht geschissen gekommen
ja da gewinnt dann natürlich meine
fingerfertigkeiten laut king war wieder
so ein bisschen 33 zeigt bis zum
aufladen
mein lieber freund so nicht ob ich da
gerade extra hin
das läuft bei mir drei akademie versucht
jetzt auch zu halten da bin ich richtig
stolz darauf diese bilanz ok jetzt ist
das schwert erst beim einsatz an
nein natürlich wieder kennt wird schon
noch auf lan 30 sekunden noch freunde
versuchen natürlich die dreierkette hier
sobald es geht auszubauen sagt dann
nämlich schon wieder ein kind habe ich
jetzt runter gefallen oder unten typ sa
genau da an die das ist das von wo wir
genau kam scheiße in meinem keller liegt
mir leid ich bin jetzt tot
doch ich kann mein leben hier auf einen
okay das war's dann erstmal für dieses
halo ich hatte glaube ich nur 20 zu 5 kg
ich weiß nicht oder noch schlechter
ich weiß nicht auf jeden fall in wiso
für mich ist das gute freunde dann würde
ich erst mal sagen wenn es euch gefallen
hat würde ich mich definitiv beide
daumen hoch freuen also wenn ihr auch
mehr halo wollt dann macht ihr noch ganz
kurzen screenshot wie macht lukas
screenshots für sales ganz einfach
ich würde gerne aber ich habe ja kann ob
die fallen grad drin
so steigerte das ganz kurz und zwar für
immer an ein spiel auf der tour dafür
natürlich meine komplette kg kaputt kann
mich noch keiner jungs könnt ihr euch
vielleicht morgen trainer das wäre echt
voll nett von euch können sie nämlich
schon killer screenshot machen
jetzt gehen runter wenn es euch gefallen
hat will ich mich definitiv pro freund
schreiben die kommentare welche pvp
sache noch sehen wollt und dann simon
jetzt mal wieder typisch